All right guys, so here is example number three for the
second distribution entry model
Right here the bias was bullish. So we had a purge here
Then we had a market structure shift here
So now we wait for another break of structure, right?
So we have a market structure shift and now we wait for a break of structure
So that week is a break of structure, right?
So now we want to wait for that for the price to take out any low
So it could be this low here or it could be this so price takes out that low
So now we once again wait for double break of structure
So we have higher high higher low and then a higher high once you have that you mark out the extreme family gap
inside these two legs, okay
Over here, so this is the family gap price comes into the family gap at 8 15 and
We simply go for one two three
Like that or whatever the target is
So yeah, that's pretty much it about this guys. I want you guys to watch this so
Lecture again and again watch the examples again and again and back test again and again. Let's move on to the next lecture